We saw earlier how scaling and then rotating is often the most convenient order.
With our snow man the arms were positioned by rotating then translating. Here's
the stick without any transform on it. I made the snowman transparent and
removed the ground plains so we can see the stick's position. It's actually
inside the snowman halfway through the ground. Whenever you create most
geometric objects in 3JS, the object is centered around the origin. The rotation
along the x axis put the stick into its proper orientation. Then the translation
moved it upward in world coordinates to the proper location. Let's see what
would happen if we first translated then rotated. First we move the stick
upwards 50 units. The center of the stick is now in place in the middle of the
body. So far so good. Now if we rotate the stick after positioning it, we
suddenly see it lying on the ground. What happened? The problem is that the
rotation takes place with respect to the origin. In the first step we moved our
stick up above the origin. In the second we rotated the stick but it rotated
around the origin. Let's watch this disaster in slow motion. The stick starts
centered at the origin. We move it upwards 50 units, now it's center is at the
right height. However, when we then apply a rotation, the object rotates around
the origin, down here, instead of rotating around its center. Finishing the 90
degree rotation, the sticks landed on the ground. Another way to think about it
is that translating an object moves its center. You're moving the object up.
Relative to the stick, you're moving the point it will rotate around down. We've
established that scaling before rotating is usually what we want. And rotating
before translating is also generally more useful. This is why 3JS uses this
order, scale, rotate, translate when dealing with a single object.